apples September event is always the
biggest one and this year at the pilgrim
Civic Auditorium there was lots to talk
about
[Music]
the big news as it is every year was the
iPhone this time it's the iPhone 7 or in
this case the 7 plus there are a bunch
of little things going on it's faster as
always the battery life is longer today
it's more waterproof because they've
changed the seal the speaker is now
better which is great but there are a
couple of big changes also the first one
is that there is no headphone jack here
instead you get piece there called air
pods they are essentially the ear pods
you've probably gotten with an iPhone
before except without the wires they
pair really easily and automatically to
your iPhone and then you just stick them
in your ear and they'll automatically
turn on music they look kind of silly
but they work the other big change and
this one I hate is that the iPhone home
button is no longer a button it's haptic
feedback the way you get when you press
on a watch or when you do 3d touch on
the screen maybe it'll be fine
eventually but right now it doesn't feel
like it clicks because it doesn't click
it vibrates and that just feels odd it's
gonna take some getting used to
so the two big things you can really see
on this phone which otherwise looks
pretty much like the iPhone 6s are the
color there are two new blacks both of
which I really like but I prefer this
matte one because it doesn't pick up
fingerprints quite the same way and the
camera the iPhone 7 has a much improved
camera a new signal processor some
faster camera taking abilities it's
better in low light but the seven-plus
is where it gets really interesting this
actually uses two different lenses at
two different focal lengths to let you
actually zoom from one point to another
it doesn't sound like much but it gives
you what amounts to totally different
photos you can also do digital zoom
which you shouldn't because that's just
cropping your photos it's gonna give you
much more versatility and control over
the photos you shoot so that's the
iPhone 7 it's out for pre-order on
Friday it'll be out for sale next Friday
and it's an upgrade over the 6s I don't
know if it's gonna blow everybody's
minds but the black looks really nice